[music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this [music]
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. As an empowered individual, you do
have options available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
found
>> [music]
>> All right, let's go ahead and open up
the doors as we are here live on Zoom,
live streaming to multiple different
platforms. And I love the fact that we
can do one show and be all around the
world at the same time. Of course, it's
not the same time zone. It's different
times throughout the world, but folks,
if you would like to join us with
Zoom live here dailywithdoc.com
is where you want to go to make sure
that you get signed up for our
newsletter and also get information
directly to your email on how to join us
here on the daily with doc.
If you want to and if you're listening
to, here we invite you to join us here
live. All you have to do is in that URL
address bar, put dailywithdoczoom.com.
That is dailywithdoczoom.com.
You're welcome to join us. So, I just
want to do a come
heartfelt shout out
as we are being broadcasted not on these
different not only on these different
platforms like Spotify, YouTube,
Facebook, um Rumble, we're going
Brighteon Truth. All of these different
places, we are also
syndicated on multiple different radio
stations. And I just want to thank
Mr. Michaels for joining us here each
and every day as he is using this
program to continue
to spread the message of hope and what
you yourself can do as an empowered
individual, folks.
We can have a better,
you know, grasp of what can and
can't
benefit our health
than somebody that's gone through
8, 9 years
of medical school, folks,
that had maybe 1 hour, one class that
touched on new This program is going to
be enlightening you on the importance of
nutrition. And with that being said, the
FDA does require us to let you know that
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician,
nor are the products mentioned
intended to treat, diagnose, or cure any
diseases. But folks, when you look at
the research of the man that we have on
with us today and you see the
comparative analysises,
taking the data from autopsies
of over 30,000 cases,
it just makes sense.
My name is Becca Dukes and I am honored
to be the hostess of this program
bringing to you the information that
gave me hope.
I was told that I had multiple
conditions and then there was nothing
they could do for me because I refused
to have go for surgery.
Um so, they pushed me off to pain
management.
And then
I found this doctor.
And he said, "Give me 90 days." I was
going to give him those 90 days and
those 90 days were over 7 years ago,
over 100 lbs ago, and no longer
having to deal with the symptoms that
have been
characterized with 13 different
conditions.
So folks, if you feel like you're just
too young to feel this old
and you're tired of hurting, listen up
because I am excited to bring to you the
one, the only Dr. Joel Wallach who has a
Bachelor of Science in Agriculture,
Doctor of Veterinary Medicine. Yes, he
started
he started with the ones that couldn't
even tell him what was going on, folks,
and he had to figure it out.
And he figured it out so well that he
has saved the white rhino from
extinction.
So, if he can save a white rhino from
extinction, I think he can really help
us humans out.
But treating the animals was not enough,
so he went on as he was teaching
nutrition at a college level for a
naturopathic college, decided to become
also a naturopathic physician and
in the whole process of it all has three
post-doctorates in pathology. So folks,
you're going to want to make sure that
you get back with the person that shared
this program with you
and tell them thank you.
This is a resource for an amazing
community. Amazing community of people.
Some of them are health coaches. Some of
them are certified holistic health
coaches. Some are just those who have a
passion to see people thrive.
So, get back with that person that
shared this program with you. Tell them
thank you and say, "Hey, I want more
information.
Can you help me out?"
If there's nobody to thank, you are
welcome to join us and go to
dailywithdoc.com
as I do have a group of people who are
here for those who haven't anybody about
longevity, have never tried the
products, and are ready to make a
change. So, if you're one of those
people, you can call our team at
855-949-3377
or go to our website dailywithdoc.com.
We do have a contact option where you
can click contact and it'll send us an
email. Let us know what you would like
to work on. If you have goals that you
would like to reach, then reach out to
us and let us see what we can do to to
assist you in making those goals. It all
has to do with you and your actions.
Okay?
The first action
is to say, "Hey, I got something going
on.
I need some help."
Admitting that you have a goal that you
yourself cannot reach on your own
because we are here to help people
thrive, folks, not just barely survive.
So, with that being said,
I started this I got to make all of
those things, all those little
statements,
um
because we are an amazing community. I
don't want to bypass anybody in our
community. I just spent the weekend with
almost 50 of them and just had an
incredible time loving and hugging and
learning with a group of health coaches.
So folks, without further ado, it is my
great honor and privilege to bring to
you Dr. Joel Wallach. Hello, Dr.
Wallach.
I know you missed me. Yes.
>> So, We miss you. You're gone for 4 or 5
days and
couldn't wait till you get back.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, it has been a interesting
A day without Rebecca is like a day
without sunshine. Oh, you're so sweet,
Dr. Wallach. Well, what do you have for
us today?
Well, I think one of the things that
people have to appreciate is that the
human body is very complex
and it requires a minimum of 90
essential nutrients just to breathe,
uh okay, to eat and digest food and that
sort of stuff.
And then,
um this requires 90 essential nutrients,
60 minerals, 16 vitamins, omega-3 fatty
acids.
And then with all these organs, you
know, you have a heart, you have lungs,
you have liver, you have digestive
system, stomach and intestines, and you
have pancreas and and so on. And then
you have uh muscles and bones and
ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue and skin and brain and spinal
cords and eyes and all the and they all
require
not only the 90 essential nutrients, but
for their functions, special nutrients
in addition to the 90. We call them
secret sauces, okay?
And so it's one of those things where
um
the old days, people unknowingly were
getting not totally because nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth,
they occur in veins like gold and
silver.
But when
they were getting all 90 essential
nutrients. Well, where did they get
their 60 minerals?
From wood ashes and coal ashes. So when
they used wood and coal for fuel for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years, unknowingly they were putting the
wood ashes and coal ashes in their food
as a spice. They're also putting it in
their gardens and they knew that when
they put wood ashes and coal ashes into
the gardens, they got a bigger yield,
bigger tomatoes, more tomatoes, that
kind of thing.
And bigger onions, more onions, and they
knew that, but they did not know that
the plants were sucking up the mineral
that were in those ashes. And when you
ate the vegetables grown in the garden
that were fertilized with the ashes, you
were getting minerals.
Well, 3:00 in the afternoon, Monday,
September 4th, 1882 on Pearl Street in
New York City in the bluff overlooking
the construction of Brooklyn Bridge,
Thomas Edison pulled the switch.
Within 18 years, by 1900, the turn of
the 20th century,
we were coming down with 50 new diseases
that people never seen before.
That's because we no longer had access
to these minerals through the wood ashes
and coal ashes, cuz we were using
electricity. There was no more ashes
that were produced to city.
And this was a big turn. This was a big
turn, going from thousands and thousands
and thousands of years of getting our
nutritional minerals from wood ashes and
coal ashes to going to electricity and
suddenly now we didn't have these
nutrients anymore. So the only way you
can guarantee you're going to get them
is to supplement. And we learned this in
the animal industry. We don't have
health insurance for animals.
Veterinarian doesn't have to come out to
the farm every day to treat the animals
like they do people, okay?
And so why is that? Well, because we
learned
from economics and from science
and that's how I learned it in the in
veterinary school as well as
agricultural school about soils and and
plants and
animal diseases.
These are caused by
deficiencies of vitamins and minerals.
And doctors, medical doctors want to
give you fast relief, so they'll give
you painkiller. Well, I just love my
doctor. I had this pain for years, he
gave me this new pain reliever, man, in
30 seconds that pain was gone. I just
love him.
But he didn't deal with what was causing
the pain, so the disease kept getting
worse and worse and worse. He had to use
more and more of the of the painkiller
and then he had to get another
painkiller, another painkiller. And then
because doctors are taught to relieve
symptoms,
they rarely get to the basic root cause
of the problem, okay? And so this is
this is what we teach people.
If you want to have healthy families,
you want to add 25 to 50 healthy years
to your life, your family's life, this
is not difficult. This is not difficult,
okay? We have
over 100 years, 123 years,
okay?
of learning how to deal with this
nutritionally in animals. And actually
with animals it goes back even farther,
okay? They learned there were certain
things. They would give salt blocks to
animals,
okay? And the animal would stand there
and lick that salt block all the time.
And people started taking salt for
themselves,
okay? Well, doctors say that salt is
bad, no? Sodium chloride are two of the
nutrients you require for life.
And if you stop salting your food,
you're in trouble, you're going to get
problems, okay? Cuz your cells won't be
healthy, you won't be able to deal
um with um
your
um blood pressure, your your kidneys
will be unhappy. You don't want that.
Every cell in your body requires sodium
chloride, which is salt. In the old
days, when you did something good,
everybody said, "Oh, you're the salt of
the earth." Cuz they knew if you had
goiter and they gave you sea salt,
your goiter would go away. Now, they
didn't know what it was in the sea salt
that caused the goiter to go away, but
they learned just from accidental
observation that if you gave somebody
sea salt that had a goiter, within weeks
their goiter would go away.
Now doctors want to use surgery,
okay? And so you have to say, "Okay, I'm
going to participate here." And then
when I started out when I was first a
veterinarian and then became a
naturopathic doctor,
I would tell my patients, they'd say,
"Well, you're a veterinarian." I'd say,
"I'm going to treat you like a dog, but
you're going to get better."
And you'll be blessed if you allow your
doctor to treat you like a dog because
you will get better.
Whereas if you're going to be treated
like a human being, uh-oh, you're in
trouble, okay? You'll want you'll be on
8, 10, 12, 15, 20 different drugs and
they're all designed to relieve
symptoms, not to prevent or cure the
disease.
So with that said, I'll turn it back to
you.
Uh Dr. Wallach, that is spot-on.
They are trained and fabulous when it
comes to like emergency medicine and if
there's something broken or something
that has to be stitched back together or
but they don't look at
the preventative
of what it takes or the underlying cause
rather
of why there's dysfunction within the
body.
So as you were going through your
autopsies with the different animals and
finding causes of death, those
>> and people and humans.
>> And people.
And you were doing that comparative
pathology, which
tell us a little bit about what
comparative pathology is.
Well, comparative pathology is when you
look at the same disease in animals and
people. And that's why they started
laboratory animals, laboratory rats and
guinea pigs and rabbits and monkeys and
that sort of stuff, so they could do the
experiments with drugs
on animals so that they knew what to
give people symptoms, okay?
But um
the
the big one was I did 20,000 autopsies
on a $21 million grant from the National
Institutes of Health.
It was based on my first
written paper, okay? And it was
published in 1965 in Veterinary Journal,
Journal of of veterinary medicine in the
United States.
I did autopsies on 50 dead lambs.
This uh farmer had um 500 lambs that
were 6 months old, they were going to
after Christmas they were going to shear
them, after New Year's they were going
to take them to be slaughtered and make
lamb chops, okay?
Well,
>> [clears throat]
>> about a week before Christmas, uh all
the professors were gone, so I'm working
my way through veterinary school,
getting paid so I can get paid the
tuition in veterinary school in the
pathology department. And this farmer
brings me 50 dead lambs. I said, "Oh my
gosh, what happened?" He tells me,
"Well, yesterday I had 500 healthy lambs
and this morning they were all dead."
What?
"They were perfectly healthy yesterday,
no symptoms, no disease, nothing. They
were eating and running around playing
like a 6-month-old lamb would. This
morning they were all dead." These
lambs, they all had goiter. Their blood
was black, not dark red, but black. So I
said, "Do you
have other farms around you?" Yeah.
"What animals they have?" He says,
"None. They all raise like hay and corn
and uh-oh. What fertilizer they use?" He
said, "Well, they use a lot of nitrate
fertilizers."
Okay. "Where did you Where did your
lambs get their drinking water?" "We
have a pond." I said, "I I need some
water." So he calls his employee and 2
hours they bring me two 5-gallon buckets
worth of water. And we analyze it, sure
enough it was just loaded with nitrate
fertilizer. Well, nitrates actually
cause
the thyroid to enlarge and and
dysfunction in this process.
And when the temperature dropped that
night, that's what happened. The
temperature went from an average of 50
for the past month every day, 50 50 50
50 50, dropped to 16
and they couldn't maintain their body
temperature and they all died of
hypothermia.
Okay? Now that was my first
scientific publication, okay? It was
published in this Veterinary Journal,
Journal of Veterinary Medicine.
Um and um I was in Africa as you point
out, working on the and doing autopsies
on all the animals in the area, the
different species of animals where the
rhino were living and trying to figure
out why they weren't making it and so
forth. And we figured it all out and
um back then there was only like 350
left. Uh last
uh December, they have 21,000 now. So
I'm very very proud of that, okay? And
we can do the same thing with humans
cuz we know what causes these diseases.
We know what you have to do to prevent
them and how to reverse them. And so
people have to make choices. Do you want
your family to add 25 to 50 healthy
years to your life, their lives, okay?
Are you just prepared to let them go see
the doctor, you know, once a week or
twice a week or three times a week, get
all these prescriptions and then work on
their symptoms 24 hours a day
and they're miserable and everybody in
the family is miserable cuz nobody's
happy, nobody's healthy, but they're
getting their medication and it's being
paid for by insurance.
Yeah, it's nice to have, you know,
somebody else pay for it, but folks,
why have it something so that you can
just take a pill?
Dr. Wallach, you were talking about the
nitrates
and that is something that has been used
in the the curing and processing of
meats and lunch meats and all of these
different things that are convenient.
>> That's correct.
And your study was in the early
1960s, is that correct?
That is correct.
The the sheep all died in 1963. The the
published it was published in '65.
Okay, so that was in 1965.
And then I know all through my childhood
we ate lunch meats.
And I had some thyroid
>> issues.
I had some thyroid issues. And then I
look at people around me and
and the questions that are coming in
hypothyroidism, hyperthyroidism,
high
all of these different things that you
in 1965
published a paper
that linked nitrates to goiter, which is
a thyroid issue.
And I am happy I am happy to see that
within the last 10 years they've started
doing no nitrates, no added nitrates, I
should say
into the lunch meats and such. So
they've
maybe figured it out and maybe they saw
your paper.
It's our job to make sure that everybody
gets this information, Dr. Wallach, not
just the few.
Because that's very possible that
it's a simple solution
to what has created huge havoc in
somebody's life.
Well, that's why we have such a high
regard for you and your team because
you're getting this information out
there to so many different people around
the world and we're very very excited
about that.
And um
we're we're picking up some more
countries here pretty quick. Um I'll be
dealing with that this afternoon. Heard
what good things that we're doing and
says, "Well, we need your help." Okay,
for 38 countries. Okay, we have an
organization of 38 countries which
you're not in your longevity program
right now, but we want to get in there,
okay? And so I'm very very excited about
this because we're going to help
millions of more people with this
information. And so get ready to be
busy, Becca.
Uh Dr. Wallach, we're we're already
busy.
You're going to have to find a couple
more people like me to help take some of
these pieces because I am just one
person. And in addition to, you know,
reaching those countries, Dr. Wallach,
we've got new radio programs and
syndications coming on as well. So
folks, if you are part of an
organization or a business where you do
have access to be able to help choose
programming and you would like to get
this information out make sure that you
contact us. We have on our team somebody
that is
um
influential
and has been a huge resource in getting
you out on the broadcast networks, Dr.
Wallach, and we're going to pick that
back up with it being more than just
radio with all the different podcasters
and
the video casters and the influencers
that are out there that people are
following on the different things like
Instagram and Twitter and all of these
things. There's too many to mention.
But folks, if you're in a position where
you would like to get this information
shared with your audience, please make
sure that you go to dailywithdoc.com.
Use that contact option and send us an
email. I will make sure that we get and
I do make sure that we go through all of
the emails and get them addressed and
uh responded to as quickly as possible.
And I had mentioned, Dr. Wallach, you
know, we have somebody on our team
that's been very instrumental in getting
you on the radio and she has her hand up
right now.
Um and
has some questions out on the different
platforms. So folks, you know, as I
mentioned, if you've got a program
that you want to get Dr. Wallach on, we
have an amazing person that has decades
of experience making that happen. So
Phyllis
what questions do you have for Dr.
Wallach today? Oh, Becca, you are you
are so kind and I do give Andy full
credit for going after the radio
stations.
You know Yes. God forbid, I could never
have done that, but um
we certainly had a whole support team
going. So that was wonderful.
Um there are a couple of interesting
questions on YouTube. Doc, you're
talking about the sheep that died
because their thyroids were exposed to
the contaminated water and then the
temperature dropped down.
And it was very cold. We have Paulina on
YouTube is asking and and this is
interesting to me living in 115° heat,
is excessive heat harmful to our thyroid
glands?
Yes, when you're cold
you're going to die, okay?
from
um
from the temperature that's too low.
When it's too hot, you're going to die
from temperature that's too high.
And 98.6 is where we're supposed to be.
Okay? And
120, I mean, you see this in in the
newspapers every day now. It's on the
TV, it's on the radio.
That these people are all dying from
heat in their car.
Their kids are dying from heat they they
just run into the grocery store for 5
minutes to get something at the grocery
store, they leave their kids in the car
seat in the car, they come back, the
kids fried. Okay?
And so it's one of those things where um
temperature is one of the biggest
killers.
Okay? Too much heat
is one of the biggest killers in
America.
Wow.
That is is fascinating and and I
certainly am not staying out to in this
kind of record heat. And we had another
question off of YouTube from Moshta who
and of course you often talk about
putting plant derived minerals on the
skin to help them get absorbed. And he
was wondering um to improve absorption
is there something else, some other
liquid or item that we have in longevity
to put on the skin to help absorption?
Or is there perhaps another route that
people can increase their level of
absorption?
Yes, what we have are ultimate enzymes.
I take
three of those twice a day. Okay? And
sometimes I'll take three three times a
day depending on how big a lunch I have.
And this is to maximize absorption of
the nutrients.
Minerals, vitamins, minerals and
essential fatty acids. But I'll I'll
tell you a quick story. Pastor Mike
Freeman up in Baltimore, Maryland. This
is about 10 years ago.
Pastor Freeman was in a coma for 6
weeks.
And the doctors called his family and
said, you know
um
pastor only live an hour or so, but
5 minutes or something. So you better
get here and say your goodbyes. He's
unconscious. He may or may not be able
to hear you, but at least you'll you'll
feel like you've said your goodbyes. So
we're letting you know that he's he's
not long for this world.
And so
his wife and one of our great
distributors up there in Baltimore,
Maryland, um Linda Tyler
um called me after visiting him and
said, "Doc, is there anything we can do
for Pastor Mike? I mean, he's totally
out of it. They're just giving him
minutes to live." I said, "Well, does he
have a a G-tube we can put some stuff
down the G-tube into the stomach?" No.
"Does he have an IV we can put stuff
into his IV?" No. "So okay, just take a
bottle of our liquid plant minerals.
I want you to take
a half a cup
um three times a day, okay? on um his
sternum
his upper belly and his lower belly and
also on his back between his shoulder
blades, upper back and lower back.
Three times a day, okay?
And
call me, you know, every once in a while
let me know if anything's happening."
Miss Linda calls me, said, "Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, Pastor Mike gets up this
morning.
He gets up this morning. He shaves. He
goes back to the church. He goes to his
TV studio, his radio studio and he
spends 12 hours telling the world about
his experience with these minerals on
his skin
to correct things that doctors couldn't
fix, okay?
And
thank God he recorded it.
And we made a tool out of it that
everybody can hear him tell his story,
okay?
It's called Praise the Lord and Pass the
Ammunition.
Praise the Lord and Pass the If you're
ever in the military, you know, Praise
the Lord and Pass the Ammunition. You
want God on your side when you're
shooting war, but you also want
ammunition to be able to shoot back at
the people shooting at you. So it's the
same way here with your illness.
God is on your side. You want God to
give everything that
is needed to make you healthy. But also
you want to um use God's tools,
okay? to defend yourself. And here again
he's telling the story on this DVD. This
is a DVD set, okay? I need at least one
of those for the family to listen to and
watch.
Oh my gosh.
And we continue to tell the story and it
really works for you little bitty kids,
you know, who are 3 months old, 2 weeks
old that aren't doing well
and just won't eat and that kind of
stuff. And the doctors just shrug their
shoulders and say, "Well, this one might
not make it." And so they rub these
plant minerals in their little bellies
and their backs and everything. And so
many of them
the next day they're just totally
different people because it's almost
like intravenous, they absorb it through
their skin.
Okay? So every family needs that Praise
the Lord and Pass the Ammunition DVD.
I'd get two of them cuz people are going
to keep them and show them to their
friends.
So, you want to get a couple of them so
you have one to share with your family.
But, this
Yes.
No, no, go ahead. You you make such a
good point that these are situations
where they could not consume the
minerals very well, yet they were very
effective. Imagine how effective taking
them internally as we do, drinking the
minerals, how extremely effective that
is. That's correct.
>> during if um
their diet is going to affect their
degree of absorption. And we talk about
the bad foods interfering with
absorption. So, that's obviously a big
piece of the puzzle, isn't it?
>> Well, yes, of course. One of the one of
the worst things that we do is um
we eat bread.
It goes way back thousands of years,
okay?
And of course, thousands of years ago
the average lifespan was 37.
And God said, "A man's years shall be
120." But, the average lifespan of
people in Europe was 37.
Why is that? Because they were eating
bread made from wheat byproducts gluten.
They could not absorb nutrition cuz
their intestines were dead.
Okay? Then in Asia, they eat uh
buckwheat. In certain places in Europe,
they eat buckwheat. There's no gluten in
it, but they do have fagopyrins and
they're f a g o pyrins which are 10
times worse than gluten.
Your intestine should look like a shag
rug with all those little villi, okay?
When you're eating gluten and and
fagopyrins from buckwheat, those villi
go away and suddenly now you have a
smooth, instead of looking like a shag
rug, your intestines look like a plastic
tube. You've lost 90 cuz I said, "I
don't know. I'm taking all these
vitamins and minerals and it's not
working for me."
Well, what do you have for breakfast,
Harry Martin? Well,
I have Wheaties, I have Cheerios, I have
oatmeal, I have uh buckwheat pancakes.
Well, that's why. You're killing
yourself with all that gluten and
fagopyrins. Stop it. And within 2 weeks'
time they start seeing benefit. Within 4
weeks' time,
they're 50% better. When within 90 days
they're totally reversed of all their
health problems.
Because now they're absorbing the
nutrition by getting rid of the bad
stuff. Got it? Thank you so much and
hold the Wheaties. Yeah, hold the
Wheaties. Yeah, hold the Cheerios, hold
the buckwheats, and hold um
hold the oatmeal.
Okay? And and and even even the
pancakes, you know, made from um
um
oats and that sort of stuff.
Uh even um
things like pizza.
We have pizza where the crust is made
from what?
Cauliflower. Cauliflower.
Or truly gluten It's not just
cauliflower. Okay, well, yeah,
gluten-free flours. It could be rice and
that sort of stuff. Millet and so so on.
But, you cannot have wheat in any form.
You cannot have wheat byproducts or oats
in any form. As best you don't even say
the word out loud, okay?
Well, and it's and it's the protein
within them that our bodies can't
digest.
Yeah, it's well, it's the
what I say,
you cannot absorb even if you are
digesting. Yes or no, it doesn't matter
cuz if if your intestines are dead, you
can't absorb anything.
That's true. Very true.
All right, Dr. Wallach, let's go right
over to AJ who has a question.
And AJ, go ahead. Unmute yourself.
Hello, doc. How are you today? Okay,
sir. How can I help you? Good. Uh
woman named Donna
is mentioning that that her
um
iron levels are high.
She's not sleeping and dealing with high
stress and she mentioned a personal
matter. Also, [snorts] she'd like to be
off of
has a hormone replacement patch, but
she's still dealing with her night
sweats and mood swings. She's 5 ft tall,
117 lb, and she's 69 years old, and she
says, "Thank you very much for all that
you do."
Okay.
So, 117 lb, right? Yes, sir. Okay. Well,
she's getting rid of all the bad foods.
No fried foods, no processed meats, no
oils, no glutens, no wheat and barley
and oats, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks. Even the diet drinks need to go
and carbonated water.
We had a very famous person a couple of
weeks ago
that he said, "I'm doing everything
right. I pay people to make sure I'm
doing everything right, and I'm still
having the problems."
And then we found out after questioning
him, he was drinking a juice every
morning. It was a juice
in carbonated water. And he couldn't
absorb because it was neutralizing the
stomach acid. You You need the stomach
acid to be able to digest and absorb
nutrients.
And if you're drinking carbonation, it
neutralizes your stomach acid so you
cannot digest or absorb.
Okay?
So, at 117 lb, I want her to have one
healthy brain and heart pack a month,
and half of those are things twice a
day. I want her to have one bottle of
our MSM a month so you take three at
breakfast or dinner time. That's going
to support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, disc between
vertebrae, bone matrix, bone cell. I
want her to have
our uh let's see here. I do want her to
have our Xerafem. She can go ahead and
take two of those twice a day. I'd go
ahead and get two bottles a month of the
Xerafem. So, if finances are not a
problem, she can take three twice a day
of the Xerafem. That's going to help her
with her um hormone issues. And then
see, we have Sleepies. She can take her
Sleepies, you know, like 15 minutes
before bedtime. All right. And um then
uh let's see here.
Uh I think Oh, she had high iron levels.
That means she's not converting iron
into hemoglobin. And so, that's where
this where the um
MSM comes in because it helps your bone
marrow make red blood cells and use that
iron to make more red blood cells
instead of letting the iron just float
around, okay?
And so, that MSM, two bottles a month,
she could take three
three times a day and that'll help her
deal with the iron issue, okay?
And so, um
let's, you know, let's start there. And
then um over time,
uh
you know, you guys can contact us and
we'll walk her through the things that
she still needs a little help with. But,
she's going to see remarkable results
with that program.
You're fantastic, doc. Thank you. Oh,
you're very kind. Thank you. You're
fantastic.
AJ's been a fantastic part of this crew,
Dr. Wallach. That is for sure, helping
us go bigger, farther, faster uh with
the the same effort in in many cases.
So,
>> enormous people skills. You
He does He does have some pretty good
>> From his profession he comes from.
Yes. From that, and I got to spend um
several hours with him yesterday and
just how he interacted with people and
he just he's just a joy to be around.
So, that fits right into our team.
That's for sure. So, thank you so much,
AJ, for all that you do. Dr. Wallach, I
have a question coming out from Virgil.
And just a reminder, folks, that if we
ask your question or you have a question
and Dr. Wallach gives you a program and
recommendations
using the products that he was very
instrumental in helping in formulating
from a company that he was the founder
of, make sure that you get back with the
person that shared this program with
you. They cared enough to share this
program with you. So, care enough about
and have respect enough for them to give
them the opportunity to help you find
that better journey to wellness because
we're in the business of helping people
with wellness, not maintaining sickness,
folks.
It's not a band-aid that or a bandage
that you put over and mask the symptoms.
We're working on the
root cause and healing.
But, you can say that, I can't. There's
See, there's things you know, you've
done all the research and you have the
that alphabet soup that's 10 miles long.
That those of us, you know, it doesn't
make any sense even though we've felt it
ourselves, Dr. Wallach,
that there is censorship like that. So,
we want to make sure that we
are somewhat um
abiding by the laws so that we can
continue to do what we are doing. That's
correct. Abide by the laws.
Yeah. But, not be afraid to speak our
truth.
So, Dr. Wallach, Virgil is a 52-year-old
truck driver and he almost failed his
DOT physical. Now, for those of you who
do not know, Department of
Transportation physical makes or breaks
your career if you are an over-the-road
driver, especially driving those big
trucks.
He says, "My blood pressure was too high
and I need to get it down without
traditional doctors and drugs.
Also, being 52, I'm curious, what
vitamins should I be taking? I have
arthritis in my hands, but not I'm
so I'm able to continue my everyday
activities." So, Dr. Wallach, for
somebody who has elevated blood pressure
and arthritis at 52 years old and a
200 lb, let's say he's 6 ft tall, I
didn't get that information from him.
What would you recommend for him? He's
asking for the vitamins to help himself.
So, what would you recommend?
Okay. He needs more than vitamins.
He needs vitamins and minerals.
And people think people people don't
have that separation that they are not
the same. They oh, I take my vitamins.
Well, minerals are not a vitamin.
And there's over what? 600 different
conditions
or health conditions that have been
linked to mineral deficiencies.
So folks, taking vitamins is not enough.
Doc's going to tell you what. Okay. So,
at um 200 lbs, I want Virgil to get rid
of all the bad stuff. No fried foods, no
processed eating by rye and oats, no
buckwheat. Uh there's no gluten in
buckwheat, but it has fagopyrins, which
are 10 times worse. No sugar, no
carbonated drinks, even the diet drinks
got to go, and carbonated water has to
go cuz they neutralize stomach acid. And
at 200 lbs, I want him to have two
healthy brain and heart packs per month.
Two healthy brain and heart packs per
month. The food loads everything twice a
day.
And then, I want him to have
uh let's see here.
Um two bottles a month of the MSM, so he
take three at breakfast, three at lunch,
three at dinner time. And they're going
to support and promote major repair of
cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, disc between
vertebrae, bone matrix, bone cell for
the for the joints and arthritis and
that kind of stuff.
And then, for the blood pressure, I want
him to have two bottles a month of our
Ultimate Daily Classic tablets. Take
three at breakfast, three at lunch,
three at dinner time. And they're going
to support and promote healthy blood
pressure and healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries in the brain, the
heart, the kidneys, and so forth.
And so, let's start there. And if he has
pain in his joints, we do have the CM
cream. He can apply the CM cream to his
joints, he'll get about two to four
hours of pain relief. Okay? And um
the uh this system
works. I mean, I've been dealing with
ProB, great story there. Um uh his
story, of course, is in in the um
flip charts coming out here pretty soon.
Great story.
And um he was so very successful. Uh I
think he's also in that CD, "Dead
Athletes Don't Lie". I think he's in
that one also. And uh he came back. Um
his career was over. He had a fracture
in his shooting arm wrist. He had
bone-on-bone arthritis
uh in his knees and his hips, and the
doctors wanted to give him knee surgery
and hip surgery, and his career was
going to be over.
And so, to make a long story short, I
rebuilt him. Okay? And we had to come up
with the healthy bone and joint pack. We
didn't have one. Okay? So, we just had a
a multiple, so we came up with the
healthy bone and joint pack, which was
our multiple, and we added the GlucoGel
to it. Okay? Which is a collagen. And
so, that made it the healthy bone and
joint pack. Okay?
And then, um we came up with our Rebound
for Theo Ratliff, our sports drink, with
100 nutrients and 75 minerals and 20
um five vitamins and amino acids. And
since he's a trucker, he can he can use
our our Rebound sports drink as well. He
wants to use If you're going to use the
the carbonated ones, do pop the tops on
them the night before you're going to
drink them, put them in the
refrigerator, then drink them the next
day cuz carbonation uh will neutralize
stomach acid. Okay? We do have the
sticks.
Okay? And on the road, these things work
very well. Uh there's one dose of
Rebound,
75 minerals and 25 vitamins and amino
acids.
Red Bull only has one mineral.
Yeah, they're just falling short, Doc.
Well, well, yeah.
They're short. Okay? Uh you needs you
need 60. We're giving you 75.
And Red Bull only has one, magnesium.
Okay? So, there's a problem there. They
have they have lots of caffeine and lots
of sugar, and that's what they're giving
you the energy with is the caffeine and
the sugar. We have a little bit of
caffeine and sugar, but it's like 25% of
what you're going to get in the Red Bull
cuz we're giving you all these
nutrients, and that's what's making
everything work so well and for so long
because it's maintaining the function of
all your tissues and so forth, including
the muscles and heart and blood vessels
and
I I think uh Virgil's going to be happy
with the results here.
And um do call us on a regular basis,
and we'll walk you through this cuz
you're going to have a great story.
All right. Thank you, Virgil, for
submitting that through email. I do have
one of our coaches on it with the
recommendation that Dr. Wallach shared
today, and that will be coming back to
you in an email.
Dr. Wallach, the next question that we
have with us today here live in Zoom is
coming from JT. JT's question is in
regards to a 65-year-old woman,
5 ft 8 in, 145 lbs, with stage four
liver cirrhosis,
anemia.
She has started on the brain and heart
pack, MSM, selenium, EFA, EFA Plus,
Ultimate Enzymes.
And she started that on Friday. She says
she's been feeling abnormally tired and
slept 20 hours.
Um so, in the
brain and bloated in the belly,
wondering what might be causing this,
and is this normal?
Okay.
Well, she may be getting reactive
hypoglycemia.
Okay? Because if she was deficient in
those nutrients, and she um had high
blood sugar, and you're taking these
nutrients, then that will knock your
blood sugar down and put you to sleep.
Okay? So, this is not uncommon. Okay?
Um but that resolves itself once you get
everything normalized.
And so, this guy here,
uh this
this woman, yeah, this woman, um 145
lbs,
uh we want her to have uh get rid of all
the bad foods, no fried foods, no
processed meats, no oils, no glutens, no
wheat or barley or rye or oats, no um
Now, let's see here. No buckwheat
because of the fagopyrins. No sugar. No
uh let's see here. No carbonated drinks,
even the the diet ones got to go, and
also the carbonated
just carbonated water has to go.
And then, at 145 lbs, I want her to have
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month. Two healthy brain and heart packs
per month. The food loads And because
she has a liver issues, additionally, uh
we want her to have um let's see here. I
I would go with the uh
I-26. Go with the I-26. Take uh we have
chewables, we have powder, we have uh
capsules and pills.
And the liver is very very important. Uh
and of course, the liver
can help you prevent
Parkinson's disease. I'm
doing all this research, and you know,
in animals that have uh chronic, you
know, wasting
disease and that sort of stuff, and
they don't have any cholesterol.
Okay? And they're just tired all the
time and losing weight and functionless
and and so forth. Well, that's because
they don't have any cholesterol. So, I
tried to find out where where where
these deer getting their cholesterol
from? Where are these people getting
their cholesterol from? Well, I can't
have cholesterol. My doctor said no
cholesterol. So, I don't eat eggs, I
don't eat meat. I just eat a lot of uh
grain. Uh-oh. Wheat, barley, rye, and
oats. There you go.
Okay? And so, so then,
um let's see here. We also want the our
sports drink, Rebound. Okay?
And um
the I'd go with the Ultimate Daily
Classic tablets. I take uh three of
those twice a day, two bottles a month.
That's going to help with blood pressure
and blood [clears throat] flow. And
also, the MSM will help with the
formation of white blood cells and red
blood cells and platelets and bone
marrow and so forth. And this is what's
going to be needed to get all this stuff
in line. Okay? But liver cirrhosis
is more than just liver cirrhosis
because
it's it the liver makes 40 different
products
that you cannot get from your food. The
liver makes 40 different things that
your body needs. So, you need to be
pumping all the nutrition to that liver
to make sure that it's doing everything
it needs to because if you don't get
what you need
cuz your liver can't make it, you're
going to get
Alzheimer's disease.
You're going to get Parkinson's disease.
You're going to get MS disease. And so,
well, my these things are for the brain.
Yeah, but the brain is 25 to 50% uh uh
cholesterol.
And your liver makes most makes 80% of
the cholesterol you require.
So, the liver
makes nutrients that support overall
function. That's correct. Live with
>> if the liver is like full of toxins,
then it's ability to be able to do those
functions aren't going to be as
successful?
Or not at all.
So, a new product, Dr. Wallach, that um
you're not quite as familiar with is
called our Ultimate Daily Digest. And
that are there's individual pouches. It
has four different uh capsules in it
that all support digestion and liver
function. So, has a little extra
something in there that helps with the
liver, and I've
had some people have amazing results
adding that to their protocol that you
have given to them, Dr. Wallach.
Okay, well, I'll read the label today.
I will absolutely.
Dr. Wallach, I have one more question
here before we have to go, before time
is up with you. And Jim is wanting to
thank us every month or thank us for our
email, our newsletter. And he wants to
know what your recommendations are, Dr.
Wallach, for tinnitus or ringing in the
ears. He says, "I'm 68 years old and
very good health,
including my hearing, but I've had this
very annoying ringing in my ears for the
last few years.
So, Dr. Wallach, per 100 lbs, because
this is not just a man thing,
it's a woman issue also. So, let's just
go by 100 lb.
What would be your recommendation to
allow somebody to give their body what
they need for eliminating
or reducing this ringing in the ears?
Well And Dr. Wallach is holding up for
those of you who are not watching the
video and are on one of our audio book,
It's All in Your Head.
So tell us about It's All in Your Head,
Doc. Well, the book
uh in the CD set, the book and CD set
goes into osteoporosis of the skull and
the 37 different diseases you can get
when you have osteoporosis of the skull.
And one of the more common ones is
tinnitus or tinnitis, depending on what
part of the country you're from.
Okay? And uh that's the auditory branch
of the eighth cranial nerve being
squeezed.
There's a whole chapter on on the eighth
cranial nerve. There's a whole chapter
on each of the 12 pairs of cranial
cranial nerves. Okay? And so there's a
lot of questions I'd like to ask this
person, but
there's one of those things where uh
they need per 100 lb body weight one
healthy brain and heart pack per month.
A half of those everything twice a day.
MSM uh per 100 lb body weight one bottle
a month take three twice a day. Per 100
lb body weight that's going to rebuild
the cartilage and ligaments and tendons
connective tissue
including bone marrow including the
skull. Okay? And then collagen peptides
is good with that with the morning
drinks or with the evening drink.
And then um we need them to have the
I26.
The I26. I like the chewables. I take
two of the chewables three times a day.
Um we do have the capsules. We have the
powder.
And they help you rebuild the myelin the
white matter of the brain and spinal
cord.
Okay? Including [clears throat] the
eighth cranial nerve. All right?
And let's see here. They also uh need
the um
uh Synaptiv. Two bottles a month so you
take two or three of those twice a day
for so the brain cells can talk to each
other.
Eat two or three eggs soft scrambled or
soft poached uh for breakfast and dinner
every day.
Um and they will give you what you need
for your brain to work properly. So all
these sort of things that people are
complaining about won't happen at all,
but if they're happening, they reverse
very quickly.
But when you read that book, I get so
many people call me and say, "Oh my
gosh, my doctor never told me about
this." Well, they don't get taught these
things in medical school and that's why
uh Dr. Ma Lan and Becca and myself we
wrote the book and the CD set. Okay? And
so we have the book and the CD set, It's
All in Your Head. Covers 37 different
diseases. Your doctor's going to refer
you to his okay or specialist. You have
ringing in your ears?
And the doctor wants to send you to his
his the classmate who's an ear, nose,
and throat doctor so you can have
hearing aids.
Okay?
Well, that's not the issue. Okay? The
issue is you're you're not getting
what you need
to have your eighth cranial nerve work
because the skull is squeezing it.
So there you go.
Well, then they've they've got quite a
network going on, Dr. Wallach. Cuz
you've got your primary care, they send
you to a specialist, that specialist
sends you to another specialist
that then sends you to sends your
information to a lab. So you know, when
people look at network marketing
I'll tell you what, folks.
Doctors have probably one of the most
expensive network marketing platforms
there is.
And what are they doing? They're masking
the symptoms. They're not addressing
underlying causes.
So Dr. Wallach, something and I know you
have to go, something that you have done
many times is referred to the good foods
bad foods list. Folks, thank you, Dr.
Wallach. We'll talk to you later.
Um but folks, you can find the good
foods bad foods list on
dailywithdoc.com.
There we have that whole list so that
you can print it out or save it do
screenshots, whatever is needed so that
you have it at your fingertips as you
are going shopping. And make sure that
you're focusing on that good side.
Okay?
If there's things on the bad side, they
just don't go in the shopping cart.
There's a lots of things on the good
side that even covers the four food
groups, okay?
For those of you who want to have a
balanced meal, balanced plate, you still
get your four food groups, but you are
eliminating those foods that are causing
toxicity within the body that have been
found to
be part of the cause
of poor health conditions.
So if I could get my co-hosts up with
me, that would be greatly appreciated
because I could not do this program
without them. Dawn Sanchez, who is my
executive production manager, I just
appreciate her and and all of her
organization and making sure everything
is the way it's supposed to be.
And then we have her assistant, AJ.
Who is not only helping make sure
everything where it's supposed to be,
but it's making it go
bigger, faster, farther, stronger
all around the world. So thank you so
much, AJ, for all that you do and
bringing in your expertise and talents
into the team. We have Sherry who has
some amazing talents also. I mean,
people skills, people.
If you've got people skills and you want
to work with people and and and help
them identifying
what might be something that's holding
them back and then having these
solutions to help them break through
our whole team is made up of health
coaches and Sherry is just one of those
fantastic health coaches that's coming
with multiple
multiple uh degrees or certificates.
There you can see has that training that
qualifies her. So we don't all have
you know, that wall behind us that we
can do that, but I love the fact that
you've done that, Sherry.
And we also have Phyllis, which I shared
a little bit about Phyllis earlier and
all of the things that she and her
husband Andy, who I just love and adore,
have done over the decades in getting
this message out to the masses. And I
just love the fact that
you know, even though Andy's at
retirement age, Phyllis is not, but they
continue to push through and make sure
that this information is getting shared
where they are able.
And we have the amazing Marilyn who is
bringing more of her skills also to the
table as she is
amazing at doing the dictation of what
Dr. Wallach is recommending and putting
it in the Zoom chat, which is one of the
benefits of us Monday through Friday
from 12:00 to 12:50 p.m. Pacific time.
So we invite you to go to
dailywithdoc.com
so that you can join us during that time
and ask your questions or just listen.
Be part of this
crusade
that is making a stronger world,
folks.
So majority of us are in the United
States,
but we are not limited to the United
States as we are going all the way down
into South Africa because folks
a human is a human is a human is. So if
one human needs vitamins and minerals
and essential fatty acids all of them
do.
So I love the fact that Albert has
acknowledged that too and he is wanting
to help his community and help us also
reach around the world. So thank you so
much, Albert. As he um has an incredible
passion and also uh experience in
distributing stuff when it comes to some
very important um
commodities around the world. So thank
you so much, Albert, for joining our
team. And folks, my name is Becca Dukes.
I love the fact that I can use my
experience
not just my experience from from work
and training and citizenship leadership,
all of these different things, raising
animals, having to to do it all and
realize that
and I came to realization that I was
looking at the labels
of the animal foods that I was feeding
my livestock more than I was for my own
self.
And for those of you who have pets, you
might be able to relate to that.
You take a lot of time and care into
making sure that that pet gets the best.
Well, it's time to consider that without
you
there would be nobody to take care of
that pet or those children or those
loved ones.
So it's time to make sure that you are
yourself and investing
not only the time that you took to
listen to this program
but taking those steps and investing in
your own health with formulations that
are proven day and day
over and over again
to be beneficial within the body.
Again, my name is Becca Dukes and I
invite you to go to dailywithdoc.com.
There you will find replays of our
programming. You will also find a store
that lists all of the products that Dr.
Wallach has mentioned today. You'll find
the good foods bad foods list. Plus
you'll find more supporting
documents and also
audios and videos
from pharmacist Ben Fuchs on the
importance of nutrition and how it
relates to health.
Get back with the person that you
heard about this program from.
If you want to get started on a program,
get back with the program with you
and ask them if they have a way to help
you get what Dr. Wallach has
recommended.
If there is nobody to thank and you
would like to get connected with a host
a co-host not a coach. Got to get the
right C word in there and you'd like to
get connected with a coach. Feel free to
give us a call at 855-949-3377.
I do have a team that are scheduled
throughout the week throughout the the
hours of the day.
They're to assist you. If by chance you
get the voicemail, please leave a
message. We do get back to those that
leave messages and we also have email.
You can use the contact option in the
menu at dailywithdoc.com
and reach us through email as well. So
until next time
bye for now.
Recording stopped.